stéphanie grammond michèle dawe et de
luc ferrandez bonsoir pourquoi ou
consoles alors la question qui était
posée à monsieur le groupe monsieur la
boue est-ce que ça a été utile le
couvre-feu à ce que les d'autres mesures
ont été utiles l'on retourne à l'école
qu'est ce qui a changé les hôpitaux
débordent encore voici sa réponse
la bonne nouvelle ça veut dire que les
mesures qu'on a mise en place qui était
dur à la fin décembre
tous ces sacrifices la que les québécois
ont fait ça a amené un résultat
actuellement sur le nombre d'inspections
qui on l'espère bientôt sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations
bon je vous soumets que ailleurs ya pas
eu de couvre feu l'école était prévu de
rouvrir en ontario lundi et les chiffres
ou six à new-york buzz on s'aperçoit on
souhaite que ça soit le pic c'est fanny
que ce que j'avais pensé de cette
annonce je pense qu'on peut se réjouir
que les écoles ouvrent il y avait
presque unanimité de la part des
pédiatres et puis des spécialistes
disent écoutez les enfants doivent être
à l'école les apprentissages ne sont
vraiment pas les mêmes s'ils sont à la
maison et puis évidemment mais il ya
toute la question de la santé mentale
donc les jeunes ont beaucoup souffert
depuis le début de la pandémie et puis
on veut pas que ça crée une génération
coville qui va être encore plus
sacrifiée donc je pense que c'est une
bonne chose par contre on aurait pu
espérer que il y ait davantage qu'ils
soient faits le du côté de la
vaccination parce qu'il ya des des
quartiers à montréal notamment où
vraiment ça ça traîne la patte on aurait
pu espérer que ben pourquoi pourquoi pas
démasqué n95 là pour les enseignants si
ça pouvait les rassurer davantage de
tests
ouvrez là excusez moi c'est fallu
m'ouvrit la parenthèse des masques parce
qu'on a construit le docteur arruda en
disant il ya pas suivi la science et
josé qu'on adore qui étaient ici cette
semaine a dit est incompétente à l'ema
docteur boileau a redit la même chose
aujourd'hui les n95 tout la science nous
dit que ce n'est pas plus sécuritaire
dans un contexte d'une école par cenet
peuple alors est-ce que c'est pas de
nous qui faisons nous et à la presse qui
faisons des lubies parfois
elles sont peut-être plus à risque les
élèves le d'avoir des d'avoir des
complications mais j'en remets pas en
question le le point de vue du docteur
boileau qui se l'est certainement
beaucoup plus que moi en matière de
sécurité et de santé publique mais mais
aussi du côté de la ventilation
j'ajouterai un c'est pas d'hier le quai
des problèmes dans les écoles avec la
moisissure ça fait des années qu'on en
parle l été dernier on aurait peut-être
pu le prendre le taureau par les cornes
pendant que les écoles étaient et tv
depuis c'est quand même dommage de voir
qu'on n'est pas encore un peu se poser
des questions à savoir si la qualité de
l'air sera bonne pour les écoles c'est
fanny vous dis depuis michel et luc je
l'aide d'accord j'imagine que c'était
demander exiger même par les pédiatres
on peut pas se permettre michel et luc
de garder nos enfants plus longtemps à
la maison c'est la folie michel
quand on regarde les avantages par
rapport aux inconvénients il semble
évident que les besoins de socialisation
de scolarisation des enfants l'emportent
largement sur le risque ça peut poser
maintenant les discours changent en à
propos des masques mais aussi à propos
de l'école par exemple il ya pendant
tout l'automne on nous disait dans les
écoles c'est devenu un des principaux
foyers d'éclosion là le docteur boileau
nous a dit non non les écoles ne sont
que le reflet de la de la contagion
communautaire c'est peut-être vrai
maintenant que comique rond à remplacer
delta mais bien honnêtement c'est
difficile de savoir
quelques lille la certitude scientifique
qu'on peut avoir
le couvre-feu par exemple la logique
nous dit que ben couvre-feu diminue les
contacts mais n'y a jamais eu d'études
qui a démontré que ça diminue l écueil
les hospitalisations il ya eu des études
en europe en 2020 on nous a expliqué que
oui le nombre de contacts pouvait
diminuer de 10 à 30% mais on n'a jamais
c'est l'adéquation certaine avec les
hospitalisations et les décès est encore
là moi je pense c'est le discours
général qui commence à changer on laisse
le couvre-feu ondes je suis pas très
remarquée à peu près personne qui a
parlé de diminuer nos contacts là on est
dans une autre face aux se faire
vacciner mais on commence à vous vrai
monsieur legault nous a laissé entendre
que d'ici quelques semaines les restos
les alors la nouvelle philosophie ce
peut-être parce que micron est une
nouvelle réalité ça dommage ce n'est
plus la limitation des comptes accès
c'est vrai il de vivre vive inverse
argent tout à l'heure vient de me dire
aussi auquel le premier commentaire sur
sur les annonces d'aujourd'hui mais
effectivement moi je pense que le
gouvernement a pris la mesure de micron
c'est à dire ça rien à voir avec les
efforts pour ne fait le jeu je pense que
ça c'est de la politique c'est une façon
de c'est la phrase qui a été choisi par
monsieur legault mais dans les faits la
santé publié jeudi on est capable compte
tenu de la baisse des cas et surtout de
la guette d'obèses la positivité on est
capable de prendre certains risques
comme par exemple le fait de limiter
l'isolément à 5 jours on sait que de
limiter des allemands à cinq jours il ya
des gens qui vont revenir et qui vont
être encore contagieux mais sont peu
nombreux et ceux qui vont transmettre
c'est une maladie une nouvelle maladie
qui est moins dangereuse que le delta
donc on se dit bon on va commencer à
jour à travailler avec les risques on
peut commencer à accepter des risques et
il y en a des risques parce que quand on
regarde les écoles sont restées ouvertes
les écoles spécialisées qui sont restés
ouverts pendant la semaine il ya eu une
désinfection de ces écoles là tellement
il y avait de quoi il y avait des écoles
avec seulement 35%
dans les garderies cv 6 % des cas
d'éclosion sont dans les garderies qui
sont restées ouvertes alors il va y
avoir des risques il va y avoir des cas
mais le gouvernement se dit on va vivre
avec ses cols oui parce que vous
soulignez vous trois changements
discours le 30 décembre ça fait pas
milan le 30 décembre c'est le couvre-feu
c'était épouvantable on allait on a on a
refermé plus aérée qu'ailleurs au canada
qu'ailleurs même en occident le
couvre-feu avait plus nulle pa et là on
dit ouais mais dans le fond il faut
effectivement vivre avec
il va se promener de toute façon
l'important c'est la vaccination est ce
que c'est le 30 on était trop sévère que
l'on le passé comme à vous réconcilier
sa stéphanie
c'est difficile d'avoir
exactement le bon timing pour pourrait
intervenir c'est mais c'est vrai que et
il ya eu un peu des tergiversations
défendant l'impression qu'on avance pas
recule mais est-ce que ce que je dirais
c'est qu'effectivement on dirait qu'il
ya un changement paradoxe a en ce moment
plusieurs médecins et ils ont dit que
l'or en ce moment et on devrait
apprendre avec eux au micro ce n'est pas
elle a même bébé que delta et que l'on
doit on ou agir différemment et je pense
qu'on est là on est rendu là et moi ce
que je note aussi c'est qu'il ya quand
même eu des bonnes nouvelles au point de
presse la ce sens qu'on voit que y'a
moins d'absents au lieu de 20 mg il ya
15000 en réseau de la santé c'est quand
même pas quelque chose de négligeable
donc espérons qu'on puisse avec les
mesures qui ont été annoncées
allaient encore chercher du personnel
puis désengorger les hôpitaux bon on
voit que monsieur legault y tient à
rendre la vie donc plus difficile
encourager le plus possible et non
vaccinés à se faire vacciner là les
grandes surfaces ça vaut peut-être
serait plus efficace d'ailleurs que
qu'une éventuelle taxe on verra michelle
et lui qu'est ce que j'avais pensé de
cette nouvelle offensive pour convaincre
les gens de se faire vacciner vous
pourrez plus locaux ce qu'on aurait pu
aller voir le match aurait pu aller au
15 mai michel
ça se fait le jour même où l' oms dis
attention la vaccination ne sera pas la
seule solution donc
oui mais ce qui est dit c'est presque
d'abord il ya cette question de
l'efficacité de la troisième dose contre
au micro une efficacité qui semble-t-il
se disparaîtrait réduire et dans un
espace assez court d'une dizaine de
semaines il ya la possibilité de
nouveaux variants aussi on l'a on parle
de la vaccination c'est important la
vaccination fortement sur l'acné c'est
notre première barrière oui d'accord
mais il faut commencer à penser là si on
veut vivre avec le les virus qui s'en
viennent donc un qui va dépasser au
micron qui sera différente au micro il
faut commencer à penser que ça ne peut
pas être la seule solution alors j'ai
l'impression que cette idée là de s'en
prendre aux non vaccinés c'est une
question d'équité c'est une question
assez pour satisfaire la population
c'est pour établir une espèce de chaîne
de solidarité en donner tous on doit
tous faire face mais en termes
opérationnels en terme de ce que c'est
juste ce que va nous permettre de lutter
contre les vagues de deux virus qui s'en
viennent pas certains
aléas les et michel est ce que c'est
santé publique houssin politique michel
je pense que c'est tout ça en même temps
et c'est sociologique aussi
oui il ya une frustration évidente là
vers les non vaccinés mais bien
honnêtement je pense pas qu'on peut on
peut se rendre tous ces gens leurs
responsables de la situation dans
laquelle on est ça aide peau mais c'est
probablement pas le principal facteur
mais là où ça devient important c'est
que si les vacciner se disent écoutez
nous on a fait des efforts un an font
pas ça vaut pas la peine d'en faire bon
on en fera pas non plus et ça c'est le
problème je pensais davantage de voir
l'effritement qui a déjà commencé en
l'affrontement à l'adhésion
l'effritement l'adhésion aux mesures
sanitaires qu'on observe dans les
sondages si les gens se disent écoutez
il n'y a pas davantage à les suivre de
toute façon on est tous dans le même
bateau
alors c'est beaucoup le japon se mesure
qui vise à susciter l'adhésion qui a
prévenu
deux nouvelles explosions oui ses fans
et de d'empêcher les non-vaccinés
d'aller dans les grandes surfaces que ce
une bonne idée ou pas moi je pense que
c'est je pense qu'on était rendu leur
oui c'est sûr que vaut mieux ne l'est
pas réparé que de que de l'arrivée avec
des armes nucléaires comme la
contribution
d'un coup c'est là si on peut prendre
des petits points et 10 rebonds ainsi ça
règle le problème
tant mieux moi je pense que c'est une
bonne idée si on peut réduire les
contacts dans les grandes surfaces parce
que quand même je me dis il ya un pacte
social de dire
on a besoin de la vaccination ceux qui
n'y adhèrent pas bien la moindre des
choses c'est qu'ils restent chez eux
puis qu'ils essaient de pas de puits
contaminés ne pas répandre la maladie
donc je pense que oui c'est c'est tout à
fait ça c'est très bien on se dit les
non vaccinés sont répartis partout au
québec tant qu aura pas de
circonscription unique de non vaccinés
qui vont faire gagner par exemple et je
pense que je m'en vais au sondage qui a
été publiée dans l'actualité qui vont
faire gagner le parti conservateur à
voir là on dit à une baisse oui une
baisse on va le voir à l'écran 38%
20 pour les libéraux 19 pour québec
solidaire qui a fait un bond quand même
appréciable le parti conservateur qui
monte 13il parti québécois qui ferme la
marche à 10 une baisse mais non mais moi
un autre premier ministre ou un
président en occident qu'elle ne telle
avance après deux ans de pandémie a pas
beaucoup michel david non
c'est un beau score c'est le score
finalement exactement de la dernière
élection pour laquelle maintenance et je
pense que c'est assez circonstancielle
parce que entre le dernier sondage qu'on
avait eu de légers symptômes street
qui était au début de décembre
on est à 46 là on est rendu à 38 à part
la pandémie la frustration que les
mesures ou engendrer ya pas grand chose
dans l'actualité qui a pu provoquer un
tel ou tel mouvement d'opinion alors si
dans trois mois dans quatre mois en tout
cas avant la prochaine campagne
électorale
le climat s'améliore et peut-être
monsieur legault le sent aussi le je
pense qui veut commencer à donner un peu
de là un peu d'air à l'électorat
ça peut revenir du côté de la cac je
serais surpris moi que le parti
conservateur du québec l'a une fois que
toutes les restrictions ne seront plus
aussi frustrante le disons se
maintiennent à ce score leur peut-être
on verra mais je prends ce
sondage là comme l'état de l'opinion
actuelle et l'habitude la lassitude mais
ça c'est pas nécessairement indicatifs
de ce que sera le résultat de la
prochaine élection
oui
[Musique]
monsieur legault a besoin d'une victoire
sur le sur la côte vide parce que c'est
pas juste de la fatigue c'est
l'impression d'une défaite la
possibilité que on on retourne à la case
zéro larron penser qu'on s'en sorte et
on pensait que c'était fini on la
pensait deux fois d'ailleurs et là on
voit on rembarque pour un tour de et
donc si après cette victoire et puis
monsieur de vouvray très rapide à la
transformer cette victoire là un
résultat personnel donc c'est grâce aux
efforts que nous avons faits que nous
avons dit que nous avons eu cette
victoire là je pense que ça pourrait
avoir un impact sur le vote mais comme
dit monsieur david si on est au même
niveau qu'à la dernière élection un peu
on ne sait quoi 36.7 dans l'état 38 et
d'ailleurs québec solidaire au site à 16
points quelque chose dont on est
revenues à la case départ il n'y a pas
de grande inquiétude pour monsieur
legault mais quand même mais quand même
il ya besoin de cette victoire des
besoins de la victoire contre la copie
mais je pense que depuis le début de la
pandémie c'était assez fantastique pour
monsieur leubou il marchait pratiquement
sur l'eau le yacht est un trou dans ses
chaussures mais ça reste que son score
est quand même extrêmement viable ça
ferait baver dans envie résine kenny en
alberta il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
donc oui évidemment et les gens avec la
cinquième vague il ya une une fatigue on
pensait qu'on s'en était pris et puis on
réalise que on a encore droit à un lot
tour de manège tout le monde s'en serait
passé et là en plus c'est qu'il ya des
codes à peu près chaque famille dont le
sens là la situation est encore plus
concrète peut-être que les vagues
précédentes où les les victimes étaient
peut-être un peu plus éloigné la part
tout le monde a des codes en somme
encourage tous comme ça ça joue sur le
moral et puis on a tendance à chercher
des boucs émissaires à chercher des
papes dont c'est pour quand même
surprenant que que le gouvernement
allait perdre un peu plus et ceux qui
devraient s'inquiéter peut-être deux
sondages ces libéraux et les péquistes
parce que il ne profite absolument pas
du mécontentement sa voix soit et québec
solidaire soit au parti conservateur
mais les deux vieux partis si vous me
permettez fonde sur place on vous permet
monsieur david luc michel stefani merci
elle ne s'est tout à coup la prochaine
fois ça lui
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit